[Música]
já que joão vitor joão vitor tem 13 anos
ele é um adolescente negro joão vitor
não tem para quem dá nem de quem receber
boa noite
já pararam para pensar na importância do
boa noite o que significa um boa noite
o momento fundamentalmente de troca é um
momento em que a gente se sente acolhido
respaldado momento em que a gente sente
que tem mais pessoas com a gente de
alguma forma também o momento de renovar
esperanças de que no dia seguinte tudo
vai ficar bem ou pelo menos vai
continuar bem no momento em que a gente
sente pertencente sente respaldado o
joão vitor adolescente negro de 13 anos
não tem pra quem dá nem de quem recebe o
boa noite
isso porque ele mora numa casa de
acolhimento em são paulo
as casas de acolhimento são aquilo que a
gente chamava antigamente de orfanato
nós não é tão adequado tecnicamente
porque a idéia de orfanato passa a
impressão de que mora lá é órfão isso
não é necessariamente verdade aliás a
minoria de quem mora nas casas de
acolhimento é órfã
a maioria tem família com o pai ou mãe
vivos
eles moram na casa de acolhimento porque
advém de famílias que não têm condições
adequadas de os criar
eles estão até que a gente chama de
situação de risco pode ser psicológico
pode ser um risco físico mas eles advém
de famílias em situação de
vulnerabilidade que os deixam em
situação de risco ea partir disso o juiz
da vara da infância precisa determinar
que eles sejam acolhidos colocados numa
casa de acolhimento para que sejam
cuidados adequadamente basicamente para
que todos os direitos previstos na
constituição e no estatuto da criança e
do adolescente sejam devidamente
respeitados
a idéia quando ele vem pra casa de
acolhimento sempre é fazer com que ele
volte para sua família de origem em que
ele volte para casa de onde ele veio
de preferência pai e mãe biológicos de
onde ele veio
ou se não for possível para aquilo que a
gente chama de família extensa tios
as avós avós bisavós dependendo da
situação
irmãos e irmãos mais velhos primos
pessoas da família com que ele mantenha
alguma relação de vínculo que mostra o
interesse que há condições de cuidar
deles sem pressa preferência ou revolta
pai mãe ou ele volta pra família extensa
o piloto joão vitor é que aos 13 anos a
família dele já foi já passou por pelos
pelos instrumentos que o estado coloca à
disposição para tentar recuperá los para
tentar fazer com que eles tenham
condição de mudar novamente desse
adolescente ou não aderir ao tratamento
ou que de alguma forma aquilo tudo não
surtiu efeito e na família extensa de
joão vitor
ninguém tinha condições não demonstrou
interesse de permanecer com ele de modo
que o joão vitor aos 13 anos mora na
casa de acolhimento e está em condições
de serem adotados e colocado naquilo que
a gente chama de família de família
substituta
você coloca uma forma de adoção por
alguém se apresente para adotar o joão
vitor
só que isso é um problema por conta dos
números a solução no brasil a gente tem
no brasil hoje cerca de 42 mil e
quinhentas pessoas interessadas pessoas
ou casais interessados em adotar
em contrapartida existem quatro mil 950
crianças ou também entrando e
adolescentes que tenha menos de 18 anos
aptos a serem prontamente adotá los
aí vão falar pô mas tem 42 1500 pessoas
querendo adotar como é que pode ter
quase 5 mil crianças esperando para
serem adotadas
o problema está no perfil o perfil
desejado por quem se habilita para
adotar um conhecido um perfil das
crianças e dos adolescentes que moram
nas casas de acolhimento e o problema
principal é a idade
só que tem uma idéia desses 42 1500 sete
interessados aceitam crianças com o
máximo dez anos
quarenta e um mil seiscentos e trinta e
quatro ou seja 97 95 por cento significa
que apenas 2,05 por cento os
interessados dos pretendentes à adoção
tocando para crianças com mais de 10
anos ea gente pode ir falando de 11 de
12 raramente vai tá falando de 13 15 17
em contrapartida
crianças acolhidas tão pronta estão
aptas a serem prontamente adotadas mais
de quatro mil possuem mais de 10 anos
significa que ele tem de 1,51 por cento
das crianças dos adolescentes acolhidos
possuem mais de dez anos em que estiver
falando de adolescente estou falando de
quem tenha mais de 12 anos e seu limite
o estatuto da criança e adolescente
previu
por isso que a conta não fecha as
pessoas que se habilitam para dotar tão
maciçamente interessadas na adoção de
crianças com menos de 10 anos e as
crianças e os adolescentes que estão
aptos a serem adotados pela vasta
maioria mais de dez anos porque quando
alguém com menos de 10 anos se torna
apto a ser adotado no dia seguinte
evitar uma família substituta que se
habilitou para adotar e que já está em
condições de ficar com ele
além disso tem outro problema desses
números a solução da crise habilitados
todos 62,72 por cento não aceitam adotar
grupos de irmãos
só que dos acolhidos 59 94 por cento têm
irmãos estão problemas que vão se
somando
é difícil adotar o quim que tenha mais
de dez anos é mais difícil ainda
consegui adoção de quem tenha mais dez
anos irmão ainda que não tenha menos de
então se eu pego um adolescente que tem
12 13 15 e tem um irmão de oito a
preferência para que ambos sejam
adotados conjuntamente que já mantêm
vínculos de fatalidade que já se
consideram irmãos mas é muito difícil
encontrar interessados por conta do
perfil de quem se habilita para adotar
no brasil
o terceiro problema a história da
deficiência deficiência que também
comporta é também abarca doenças
crônicas doenças tidas como incuráveis
aqueles habilitados todos não aceitam
crianças com deficiência 93,74 por cento
em compensação possuem alguma forma de
deficiência de fãs de deficiência física
que 52 58% das crianças não aceitam
crianças com deficiência mental 41 mil
70 dos habilitados a obter seja com 62%
dos habilitados não aceitam crianças com
qualquer forma de deficiência mental
em compensação possuem deficiência
mental 14 1% dos acolhidos
a gente fala de deficiência mesmo entre
o técnico da pessoa com deficiência não
se usa mais a expressão
necessidades especiais pessoas especiais
pessoas com deficiência é o termo que a
lei usa essa questão que surge como é
que a gente faz para conseguir resolver
o problema do joão vitor
ele é um adolescente negro de 13 anos
exatamente onde vem de uma família
periférica de uma família em situação de
vulnerabilidade social
brasil um país extrema desigualdade
social
o índice gini que mede a desigualdade
social aumentando de forma cavalar
constantemente atingiu recentemente o
maior índice da série histórica
malanje o pior índice da série histórica
quanto maior o índice gini
pior o índice da série histórica atingiu
piores da série histórica mostrando que
a desigualdade social é um problema
profundo no brasil a gente tem 52 mil 52
milhões e 500 mil habitantes que morre
vivem abaixo da linha da pobreza 13
milhões e meio de habitantes que vivem
abaixo da linha da extrema pobreza
significa viver com menos de 145 reais
por mês três milhões e meio já tido como
um país democrático se ainda dá pra
dizer isso mais desigual do mundo mas em
todo o mundo por esse índice é capaz
é nesse quadro que tal joão vitor a
gente precisa encontrar uma família em
que ele possa ser inserido e fala pouco
mas a gente vai fazer para resolver esse
problema eu trabalho no tribunal de
justiça de são paulo a gente cuida das
varas de acolhimento do estado todo das
casas de acolhimento do estado todo
existem milhares e milhares de crianças
e adolescentes acolhidos cerca de 8.500
no estado
vários deles com esse perfil a gente tem
que dizer pensar formas de resolver esse
problema por onde está o posto vai ficar
parado de braços cruzados se a gente
continuar agindo como a gente sempre
agiu
a gente vai continuar tendo os mesmos
resultados que sempre teve
a gente vai continuar vendo joão vitor
fazer 18 anos saindo da casa de
acolhimento tendo que se virar sozinho
a gente falou bom então vamos fazer o
seguinte vão procurar uma solução que
seja pouco ortodoxa dentro daquelas que
a lei nos permite tomar é possível que
não tenha forma de sensibilizar as
pessoas encontram um problema de cara
muito sério
os leigos quem não está trabalhando em
direito e mais especificamente na área
de direitos de crianças e adolescentes
raramente sabe o que é uma criança que
mora na casa de acolhimento porque ele
falar de onde ele vem né que condições
levam aquela situação
então o que nos parecia ser a primeira
solução era dar visibilidade para essas
crianças e pré-adolescentes gente vive o
mundo hoje absolutamente imagético as
pessoas estão com o celular o tempo
inteiro apontada para si
a gente hoje presume quem está com o
celular assim tá tirando fotos de si e
não está pra lá no celular é uma coisa
diferente do que era há 10 anos né
um dos fundamentos imagético que as
pessoas se auto promove em cada vez mais
então a gente esconde os adolescentes
que moram na casa de acolhimento
adolescência de novo que vem de regiões
periféricas que sofrem todo tipo de
preconceito que alguém pode sofrer
preconceito de origem preconceito racial
é não raro a população lgbt que sofre
preconceito também pela orientação de
gênero e além de tudo ele ainda sofre um
machuca mais perverso dos preconceitos
todos porque na classe da escola em que
estudam as pessoas têm mais ou menos a
mesma origem
mas ele lá ainda ouvir que ninguém quer
ainda ouvir que nem a família dele o que
é que essa forma mais perversa de
preconceito que alguém pode sofrer
ele ouve tudo isso ea gente esconde a
gente reforça a idéia de que ele não é
digno de ser mostrado que ele não é
digno de aparecer de que tem que ficar
mesmo escondido ali era um problema
outro problema é que a gente faz para
exibir esses adolescentes para exibir no
gosto de mostrar esses adolescentes para
o público sem que isso sem submeter ao
ridículo sem que ele seja visto como a
de coitado por todas as dificuldades vão
virar um coitado é um sujeito de
direitos
ele é um adolescente que têm os mesmos
direitos de qualquer outro adolescente
que estuda aqui
o estudo encontrou com líderes do brasil
os mesmos direitos que a constituição eo
estatuto da criança e do adolescente
prevê direito à cultura à educação à
saúde ao lazer à convivência familiar
principalmente como é que faz para
compatibilizar a exibição do adolescente
mostrasse adolescente público e
mostrá-lo como sujeito de direito é mais
importante a gente não quer despertar o
espírito caritativo ninguém
a gente quer posicionar-se adolescente
como sujeitos de direito que
efetivamente é
conscientizá-lo do direito que ele tem
pra fazer isso a gente procurou uma
agência de comunicação f/nazca uma
agência de publicidade aqui de são paulo
para apresentar esse briefing tempo
depois eles vieram com a idéia de
criarmos um site um site aberto ao
público esse site no ar um site restrito
a quem deseja voltar a um site aberto ao
público
e aí a gente criou no tribunal de
justiça de são paulo o programa adote um
boa noite retomando aquela idéia da via
de mão dupla como é a adoção adoção é
necessariamente uma via de mão dupla
a gente sempre pensa na adoção como
pintado tando recebendo que está sendo
adotado mas o inverso também é
verdadeiro
se a criança ou o adolescente não adotam
o casal que se apresenta pra eles alusão
a uma certa evolução é necessariamente
uma via de mão dupla tem tudo a ver com
um boa noite
quem deseja adotar também precisa
receber uma noite também precisa ter a
quem dedicar um boa noite
esse é o grande ponto do nome ea gente
criou um site aberto ao público fotos de
crianças e adolescentes que efetivamente
estejam nas casas de acolhimento
só que são fatos reais não são atores
não são distrações são fatos reais de
crianças e adolescentes que moram nas
casas de acolhimento e mais que isso a
gente tinha que criar esse site
posicioná los como sujeito de direito
mostrar que eles têm sonhos que eles têm
desejos que ele tem o direito de sonhar
também é uma coisa que é muito focada
neles desde sempre
normalmente a gente até lá a foto a uma
frase indicando que essa criança que é
esse adolescente para participar do site
eles precisam ter esse foi um corte que
a gente estabeleceu a época pelo menos
oito anos porque em 2017 quando o
programa foi lançado o programa foi
lançado no dia 12 de outubro de 2007 das
crianças e foi lançado no jornal
nacional porque acabou a noite mais
famoso do brasil
eles fecharam promocional com uma
matéria com as crianças desejando boa
noite pra quem estava assistindo a
participar do site eles precisavam
precisam ter no mínimo oito anos porque
a partir dos 8 anos começa a publicar
hoje essa barreira já está em 10 anos o
que mostra que a gente vem aos poucos
conseguindo sensibilizar as pessoas mas
apenas dois anos que aconteceu
ou então de alguma forma de deficiência
por conta dessas dificuldades todas para
a deficiência não têm idade porque é
sempre muito difícil
colocar em família substituta alguém que
tem deficiência e mais que isso eles vão
ter passado por um estudo psicossocial
técnico que mostra que eles
compreenderam a razão de estarem no site
que vão tomar a inclusão no site como
algo positivo independentemente do
resultado final
a idéia do site não é exclusivamente à
adoção a idéia do site é posicionar
essas crianças como sujeitos de direito
é mostrar quem são essas crianças e
adolescentes que reflita sobre eles e
claro também para quem esteja chegando
para votar pense sobre essa
possibilidade de lutar um adolescente
isso não faz parte do nosso imaginário
a gente fala na adoção as pessoas
normalmente pensam em adoção de um
bebezinho de uma criancinha
o que é absolutamente legítimo não tem
problema nenhum nisso a gente tomar
muito cuidado também para não condenar
em contrapartida quem se apresenta é
adotar uma criancinha é absolutamente
legítimo que esse seja um sonho de pai
ou mãe total um recém nascido era uma
comunicação difícil de ser feita por
conta desses cuidados tudo o que a gente
precisava tomar a partir do site foi
portanto lançado do youtube lançou o
projeto em duas varas que servirão de
piloto
as varas de santo amaro tatuapé na
cidade são paulo santo amaro é a região
com maior população entre as varas da
cidade de são paulo são mais de 3
milhões de habitantes cerca de 500
crianças que os adolescentes acolhidos e
tatuapé por conta da questão de haver
muitos adolescentes com deficiência ali
a gente colher as duas horas piloto só
para se ter uma idéia são mais ou menos
330 varas da infância no estado de são
paulo na cidade de são paulo são 12
varas da infância a gente pegou duas
para fazer esse piloto começar
devagarinho
a partir disso desde que o projeto foi
lançado
a gente já conseguiu 17 adoções
concluídas sentença transitada em
julgado
o nome de quem está votando no registro
de quem tá da criança adolescente e mais
29 processos ainda em curso porque 29
processos em curso porque é essencial
que a gente tome cuidado para não
colocar o carro na frente dos bois
é essencial que a gente faça isso com
calma porque apressar as coisas
significa colocar a criança em nova
situação de risco
a gente toma muito cuidado para que o
vínculo havido entre a criança ou
adolescente e quem tá botando seja
formado de modo substancial firme porque
a pior coisa que pode acontecer é aquilo
que a gente chama
popularmente de devolução da adoção
tecnicamente não existe mas é o nome que
se usa o vínculo não está formado de
modo adequado a gente quer ficar ansioso
para fazer a coisa andar rapidamente
achando que isso é bom pra criança e um
ano depois a gente percebe que aquele
vínculo era frágil e isso começa a dar
problema é o pior quadro que pode
existir porque é uma rejeição em cima de
outra rejeição
então por conta disso sempre gente ouve
falar adoção é demorada tal tem uma
razão ser demorada porque a gente
precisa fazer as coisas com calma é
lembrada por ser um filho com humano
a gente se esperar esse vínculo se
informar de modo sólido adequado é um
vínculo afetivo a gente não tem como
apressar isso de novo todos aqui pessoas
pelas quais não havia nenhum interessado
no brasil também é um requisito para ter
um site
significa que hoje estão adotados 17
adolescentes pelos quais até então
aparentemente não havia nenhum
interessado no brasil ou crianças com
alguma forma de deficiência além de 29
processo de adoção ainda em curso
por conta desses resultados a iniciativa
recebeu o prêmio innovare
o tribunal de justiça premiou valeu o
prêmio mais importante da capitá da
comunidade jurídica no brasil
é um prémio é entregue pela instituição
para instituição vai e tribunal de
justiça recebeu a categoria tribunal
em 2018 o prêmio innovare por conta do
dote um boa noite
eu estou mencionando aqui o joão vitor
na verdade foi obrigado a usar um nome
fictício embora a gente coloca os nomes
verdadeiros no site foi obrigado a usar
um fictício porque na verdade o joão
vitor tem outro nome
hoje ele tem 15 anos adolescente negro
eu precisava dizer que além de tudo é
soropositivo
ele entra na categoria de deficiência e
ele está vivendo com uma família
interessada por ele ele é um dos 29
processos em evolução
mais que isso joão vitor tem uma irmã
que hoje tem 19 anos ea família que está
adotando levou também a irmã pra morar
com ele
aparentemente é que é o caminho a ser
tomado mesmo obrigado